نا في الهدنه اول يوم على بيت حنون مرقت
اول الزيتون احنا ارنا في الزيتون في
الزيتون في بيت حنون اول ما مرقت كل الدور
مهشه بتعرفش تمشي كل الدور دمار الله كل
الدور راحت كلها كلها كلها قد ما تتصور
بقوللك كلها كلها امشي يا خالتي في الشارع
واتفرج احنا راضيين ترجعونا وتخلصونا
الحرب هذه واحنا راضيين في خير بتحطو حسيت
حسيت بموت يعني تمنيت ان استشهدت قبل ما
اشوف الدار الدار المال معاد الروح المال
معادل الروح لما بتروح كل الدنيا انا مي
25 نفر الي ثلاث كماين وكل واحده معها وين
بدي اروح ولادي وين بدهم اروح دول وين
بدهم مكنوا انا بقول لكم راضيه بال الخيمه
بس رجعونا على دورنا يا عمي هم جد ما سووا
فينا ماخدوش مطلوبهم لكن احنا منصورين
بامر الله شبابنا منصوره بامر الله وال
معاهم والله ملاقي ج تيجي تتلفون مع
اولادنا والله ملاي تمها مع اولادنا والله
منتصرين الواحد الاحد الا نتصل على اليهود
عدو الله الا احنا ظ منصورين و فينا ما ما
احنا
راحين